bac à bac is inside
the
restinga and exciting of the disc have
you women karine buggy and co founder
and see you philip hammand on google
machine learning developers expert in
standby happy to be here today everything is
there they have with eight initiatives
added  king for tunisians ecosystem
and some interesting things to discuss
beat for apps for that i want to marry
data manager yes cj watson said rafa i have
this year europe as well as mr freeze
magis high speed yes
hello to all air conditioning bi and yes i am
team leader in the
digital transformation program of the age and yz
in tunisia the gélise aide supports
since the beginning of the year of the walls of
bi at the beginning of 2021 a very important project
for tunisia which is the development of
the national strategy of  artificial intelligence
we do it in partnership
with the ministry of
mining and energy industry and the ministry
of communication technologies
so the development of this strategy also
passes  if by the creation of an
Arab state which is hosted at the dot where we
are today and the objective
through the iops and to accompany the
development of national strategies
and to ensure its implementation and it is
in  this framework there that we have
today this press conference
that kiki who goes which is also a
partnership with an i-p stadium
it is within the framework of ja
and maple that our development of
partnerships as well with the
private and public sector we give we
train ourselves implementing
artificial intelligence solutions that
serve companies and the public sector and
the private sector
so without further ado I'm going to leave the
floor to a surface but I say they
who is our partner  for the
implementation of this action plan around
artificial intelligence that we
have already initiated and that we will
continue until
2023 with the support of Algeria to be
in fact I am happy to see a
friend first but  secondly someone
who does honor to Tunisia a
Tunisian skill who was
able to achieve in such a short period of time
technological and technical and
managerial prowess important that she has
lost weight so in fact it is a
reunion
that  are already going up which already dates back to 2019
where the cooperation started with a
stadium i with the ministry and there we
started a project which is with an
ninth which was a haka time organized
by a stadium iep and in collaboration
with google and with the  ministry and
it was already a very
fruitful cooperation insofar as we
really crystallized the
entire binder ecosystem in Tunisia and we
really shouted a mayonnaise to
further develop
artificial intelligence in Tunisia
so a reunion after  after two
years but
also morning in a moment to
turn in a in a very
important moment because already with
and the ministry of technology we
already have  started the realization of the
national strategy of
artificial intelligence and for which we
need all the actors
whether public and private or civil society
the journalists also
is besides today
in the morning we are preparing  we are in the process of
providing training for
journalists to cover this kind
of activity so it is a
very important moment and for which we
really congratulate the contribution and the
competition of a stadium for for I  I'm
not going to be surprised to really
strengthen this initiative at the level of
the national artificial intelligence strategy
, which will be announced right away
with kévin bérigaud kalimba gear, it
really constitutes a very
important stone for the building, it's an added value,
no  only for for the
strategy but also for the
whole ecosystem of
artificial intelligence and in addition that it does it
with generosity in the free is
really in the mistletoe  baccalaureate for
the whole ecosystem what he is going to
announce is really something
very important a salutary initiative
and I hope that the
whole ecosystem will take advantage of this
generosity and what will be  offered
free of charge for the ecosystem so without
further ado while
once again thanking an ip stadium and the gelise and
for their support and their contribution I
invite to a fight
to announce the surprise
5th case the galetas wilileaks has helped
and life but there  like holding the left thigh
ok it
continues to collaborate
minister said paul abbott the doing that we
criticize but kingson apple and iraq
tunis a dynamism and another life
continues 100 think you tube experts
so to day like jump into it but prague
this few words abbott in-stat di for bi
for you gives nuptials
bgc linked to co-founded company in tunis
a third fault chinese would have
slim you manage a tourist today we
are in 6.92 on the back of a donkey sistine playing
running b  ack importantly or established
earth hour has innovator a fog
leader in de bulimia erigène europe
middle east and africa built that the
lebanese as you say so young making
eia irving glasses and go either to
and complex problems on the saint
pauloise innocence very proud of in team
jesus majority tunisian las been able
to basic libya like an elite world
notw nvidia speech therapy 6 companies in
right on twice nominated hunters point
of most promising company in the world
until our brothers five years old said
passerby ordered
sagardian credential review  roof neither you nor wan saw
wolverine and sisters of africa part
of audi accomplishments matricide april to
castets pts 12 months year many ways that
what you want to do in tunisia
has and the inca potential to be exposed to
africa the world sort of  six la capa
elliott program built fit works we
might consider expanding to more more more
we jones american trip in the
mix live to mount all and he obstin  ine
datolo
figeac you got them fantastic yalta rally
team death by rob simmons concrete redit
a time in the world we have five google
machine learning developers exploit
in our sleep
doug weight including china india you
are not so many of them are tunisian
you today
death is  to say that we have expertise
in tunisia worse for capable holding
amazing things are getting going
for example like for iraq tunisia we
hate death of 900 men just
participants won 6-0 at strings 19
hours specific stocks but i
remind you that we  supports a little bird
divine initiative banda samba dia in
the before sunrise like this is
completely new in stadium rats it
was a little suspense amazing made in
vibes besides when white forest or
to ride or a fan ten buildings
carry in price yes  discord really nat
2 him the patient for you in big three
city of cali and some of the winners of
the current competition continue to
rise and rise i  n fine it is above all
the match and nepotic the present time
and firas baba poses at the fantastic
Tunisian talent who I am an
international court competition and gold gold
medal for it i might have seen
news limit wallace baba was one of the  winners
of
writing and state and death is to show
your job list of light peak structure in
heaven know value the whole ecosystem
of halos people to push of capabilities
tower of max discovery it does not
send international thanks to the drawing example
the  offers one story initiative in the
north on two 48 have been in tunisia
jump it leaks and fridges tunic slide
before all a date beam and our two
scans of light the event eco system initiatives
the knesset continued inc we just
co-organize drif in tripoli  a soup
like indaba ex Tunisian something else the
big success and we are life sabine bonaly
a
hymen it leads to open the
co-organization of 6.28 chosen great
success his butt mound campus ten
univer  sities the other sands of interests
of death is to say verist at the
niger and space institute bet you know that so
above all his international talent
freight the place of five breaks or
softened need to do amazing finn jr
thought of light spread to positive
thought of light development wish the
series sherlock will i to iii tunisia we
all know who dat unies of the united states of
the crisis truncheon d'horizon annual sony
computer
infiniti killer with we look at what
happens when all of them come together
with interesting things to  nextlight they
are above all ten headphones beats gold
experience qu l'abri think we love and
other brilliant united young start up high
compass all developed in bertso f
comeback once again the bird and bird
in innovative sort money project and
product de first de  tunisines dialect
based thought of link and yahi
specialized systems modern kitchen mayotte what
is increasingly est date and thuc
indeed state capabilities a small
reward to john  great work jean becker
for the state off abbott direct and also
like it shoes like the nike tn sadi
contributed computer expertise and sue
team stiggy current and remains on ten
expulsion compass management willy
innovate to represent the left
we just said that  and we
will change chichi present to you yes
from altitude announced at tmz
ain't got him from my compass beast to have
touched did he explain how it is
bobby campo tures innovate bathing
holding li zhanshu heart of eta computer
and innovation
week-  end with timings morgen
insomnia think about you this way of
life becoming of indecisive programs eo2
shows just as incredible without
ferrari evolution sees you signs of file today
s date viable model in our school
transformed to libya like a joke
of standards everywhere and  artificial
intelligence
a taxi sting because they come back to
the oven room worse the iraqi cus
of trials in the world from brand 1 2
5 km screwed investor form  silicon
valley and one of the cult of netscape
recipes he came out of it think the world
and how we have said planning eating
software andy plein coup de bissy nasvax
of two zero hour bésicles program
sabine green bay transformers writing
diploma ni ni except at served saturday
around the  painting relaxes the sorter india
of complications verifies that all this
is status nor of morals misunderstood by
dati 2.5 lac dows world to confessions and
consultant grid räikkönen
process of transformation come back to
your style
quadratic insi queensland
[Music]
the main event at  stevenage compute
capabilities to get quang ngai
binh chanh tu which may not before
transformers 2 event des world
afterwards web shape and zekri machine
learning computer board soto
puddles ball z rihanna finances hans beck
is strong bad attack and not
until crisis
and asturias the
guy made a pact just one
quick look to tell you date there is a
stadium glasses i will be contribu  ting to
from tunis general ecosystems diginext and
oneworld this super computer
band planet
challenger activity shuttles from nasa
compass
five lines or and hydraulics from state
of the art in like you were
here we look and from sfax like once
then pourvoir was born in
damvix  du rav ait gpu ati gigabyte snow
leopard 10.6 massive squats important
in africa for example language model
which to a balance sheet award offered
the united states date kind of mabri de
compubase lifesite petaflops this sector
may be made the wall street walking
about five million des
[Music]
concrete and significant family ties
importantly and that just computers and
just like budget and his support for pfizer
like speed be cause of a rapidly rising vote
or such place and date a stadium manager
wearing glasses gonna have a permanent except
three years at 12 p.m.  you working with the one
that up and is an essence halloween
people to materialize from 10 a.m. dr jack
snyder ac non founder working in tunis a  u
stadium jean reno project and just like to
his body the crisis 'passionata lac doing
something like my project that night on
temporize jobs web
useful to race supports but cause of the
following seasons unia and syna than
expected 0.6 in six dates otherwise the
system
complicated
will hunting stage it works we
support to make sure
then to call you on a diet
accept to use super computer can
actually monster monsters out of it can
actually gatineau be at the frac de
resolve looking for we have accumulate
haiti and world of expertise  doing this
ain't over to say that we have world
class and eisenstadt in-stat deep
including current and a new
turning photo
catherine coste ex-colleague that had
been in tunis solo evenings except
expertise will be made available to
select from jax  sonata in do you have of
driving per hour beaten at the rav of
advise best use it kind fusing mode
modern soft return of the complex manager
a frozen black invoice so we believe
th  e start of having rini transformation
the impact into ecosystems
music literature afro jazz take off 1
except like heaven
brive expensive care means when
a pact
25 years the parnassus see making
sports if bobby brown sugar gesture in
static and under the seal of  an
oblique other stick shelters this Arab country
with supporters jay z there are all of them
tunisian ministries it industrial s
is put before the telecom leap this
product is furibard guild of
ecosystems to be the best in africa from
bessines
to  current embellished is it possible
isn't it so good rounds positive
win-win reverse collaboration of spirit
of what we're doing this is not
something new dawn stadium yves hardy
gautama house of success wished
we passed stars too
d  experience date yes smiles a clue
everything what is lacking weekend or death to
zaman Chaudhry had decided at this
stop light f10
significant ecosystems initiative
is that goodman the success and i
know  we a tunisian or
international ebook jean used to use
hindu systems to my staring
flour eyes been done before lacquered start
up to take off productive casino
and iphone danguel developed and
competitive our local life certainly
offered competitiveness what a beast
globally  competitiveness that of the six to
eight majors success for death
initiative our soul optimistic and
thanks to die for that are currently
being dubai mall ps willy means that a
fold invested munich to the hybrid system
workers with chance to offer neither tomorrow
nor talence of discontent at enbridge
nba
the impact beats and exxonmobil success
on nerves otherwise illizi atentat deep whif
their talent in togo of helios hindu
grooming
believe it's very important person you
give back brad we don't forget to reach
the get fooled bin al foul you have to  6.5
and boots and not an asepex particle
especially since this new mobile world
congress it will not have size - 12:25 at
your leisure and
national but  in fine it will be for you
it follows the ten other positive puddles
because my mentality if you do the right
thing to
do with
the future and roll ford ecosystem and
beyond enso baby the nex-5 severine
actually all flat and this in the name of its
unilateral acts and nissan offers a
real machine of nine project ringo
starr prowler kanak you say to plan the
wadding forms the origins life we will side
roject space of rim techn
cal exit pact hall feasibility m we want
o be free so please des to dream
it  there may be benedict digix crowd
of systems with bolt on you for
free yamin and then to turn disappoints me
narrative installed by skillful
williamson and original decision made
in potential ain't gonna come easy money
to work over and over  ip
158 also what you tube bling
we have a training session to
train journalists is specialized
in artificial intelligence
they have a two month training but
they are only on their first
week  training on artificial intelligence
they are there with us and I invite them to
ask questions in Arabic in
dialect or French in English and in Japanese or
Chinese you do not worry if
you have questions to ask there is
not silly questions there are some
of the answers of the plia balance sheets all
questions are welcome even
questions that seem simple to you or
questions that are not very
easy so ask the question take the opportunity
to get answers and
insights from people  high
caliber good high quality there in kelly
but there are also
two great experts at
international level 2 there are as
he said there are almost 2
how many people 200 people in
2000 people google experts have  200
people we already have here from hall 3
ints and mine from we already have two
among 200 international experts in the
world ok so
don't hesitate to ask questions  s
to his mom
has capital skills are not
halal my question is what to cover him
with confinement remote work
it was an opportunity for them an
obstacle
i will i will answer in french
for the hearing it actually takes c  is
always the same every obstacle
can be turned into an opportunity and
indeed for us it was worth starting
was a great challenge that we then
managed to transform into an opportunity and
I would say that for people
who are working in the
digital world  and ai in particular there
are no particular obstacles to working
wiimote and that net net remote is
perhaps an opportunity for
tunisia because if we compare
today the number of job offers
wiimote in the world
compared to what it was before the
crisis I think we went from 15 20
% to 70 80% it's a colossal change
and it's an opportunity for Tunisia
for an iep stadium  that she would be for
example  mple
the added value on the Tunisian economy,
that is to say a trustee, what could she
bring to the Tunisian economy since
she works on the ai and it's good
we see the phase shift between, that is to say
the economy
but she has gone to a
somewhat embryonic stage and what could
bring a stage that she works
in the ict sector is the sector
that has a very significant added value on
a global scale so I think the
thing  most important that we can
bring first of all is jobs
and skilled jobs I think there is
nothing more important for the country than
to keep its skills and
nurture them and that they develop and
therefore succeed in  a stadium ippj say and this
is our first contribution and the
second contribution I would say on a
scale
more economic models and others it is
we want to prove that
Tunisian talents can succeed in
deepstack innovation while waiting for this for a very
long time to think
that text innovation is happening in silicon valley or
in china now but that there is
no chance of creating businesses that
are globally competitive and that
they are largely based
in the country well  I think it
's evolving and my dream would be for
an ips stadium to be a kind of
Tunisian success story which
reminds me that we started with
laptops and 5000 dinars that we struggled
for very very  long years before being
able to accelerate but to show that
finally the dream is possible and that
it is concrete jobs
of innovation and
long-term skill acquisition is to make
the country evolve towards an
economic model which is I would say
well in harmony with the opportunities
of the 21st century
you vote by the great powers et
cetera and
configuration i.e. how
could it be used there to
bring surprises of sure
i.e. renovation i.e. bring  a
knowledge  very high level area yes
that's actually the beauty
of artificial intelligence is that
of course it's a power issue
for the big countries the united states
china etc but in reality our
experience in ir shows  that a small
team but very talented with the
right culture the right monique and the
right motivation can work miracles
so the ai is a team work but
it is not necessarily a work of
the team  1000 people is more a
team effort ii a hundred
people if these people are
extremely gifted extremely
competent extremely motivated it is
possible to do great things in
any case this is what we want to prove
and in  doing so we hope that others will
be inspired and believe in their dreams
and also get to work and
therefore this ripple effect that we
hope to have but today but I
especially if you have the means of
calculation of which  there is no
need to talk  a team of thousands of
people to do something
world class I would even say that with
an excellent team of a dozen
people with the right means at the
computer you can do fantastic things
it is important
that there is this
real project between dictatorship
and in a different way you don't need a
lot of diplomacy you don't forget to find
an ultimate stadium the calle del potro
looking for you looking for evidence of
mobility like and fuel been doing pro
jake song finds there for example  for the
coach interesting web they have trouble
flat ni m
and yes yes if diplomat
except line with this is now done bility
to bind this four fantastic
Bulgarian diplomat of benefit of the
dance en bloc a whole staff but even
better dated like wesley  any
ride current project post in a guide
rab 125 guidi fantastic original
things at least are motivated
yes
without hesitation all flat
overall said relax the people will looking  for
people who have done made in france
and short of the crisis there are
classics like say they need you been
very persistent to get some of
working  So there you have it, in general the
Tunisian government was very
Thursday to really encourage startups
in Tunisia I would say in particular the
startup acts it's
something innovative there are a lot of countries that
are following us now on the starter
pact pie one  stage i did not benefit
from the startup acts like
many tech companies in tunisia and we
saw the ripple effect it
allowed us to recruit more talent
faster and that is something
great so i would say yes  the
Tunisian government listened,
we developed an excellent
relationship with six elderly women,
major events such as and will win, which
could not have taken place without
the support of  he Tunisian government
now in terms of the game would say
development policy I think that
what we are succeeding in
Tunisia is this notion that
ultimately innovation and
risk-taking it is for us at the
level of the stats it does not  must be at the
level of the ecosystem the role of the state
and whose courage to create a climate of
confidence a positive climate with the south
but I would say that in relation if we
look for example at the grand plan of the
generation of our parents by  example well
it's somewhere the world
of ateq level is evolving at such a
speed today that it is better to
let the start-ups who work
concretely in the field
find opportunities and move forward
very very quickly and that it  is a
full-time, full-time job the role of the state
is to create the framework that allows all this
and I would say that it is already
something fantastic what we have
in tunisia there are many countries in
africa and  in the world has  rabe who are
not lucky enough to have a state that
supports them like the Tunisian heap
supports startups people I'm going there we're
in the right direction
we have to continue and we have to
let our talents express themselves take
their chance  take risks and is
dark
does she explain that less funny production
is that I defend you read tribute to
goodwood dates the other value of
Tunisian ecosystems bataan ghana
surprisingly
politically to do what would be amazing
we actually everything to
the collective reception of  new types
stats stats touraille experte forints
alan quine 10.4 and semmering nature
canada and foreigner in deep tech i want
unige to tobe reading sailing ecosystems
youtube at least to lahoud possibility of
doctor who sold the world to come here
nba if there is a very  talented perceived
as a form brought to certain tony
g a small tunisian dog on board like
he substantially
small than middle finger subtitles i'm
here is thought of light and  used
opportunities liberal political difficulties
have
already signed the young driver very
few and x-files and vlb world wide and
freeman who combines
world class and tunisian experts and edge
of this you it's great job
major opportunity towards a world weekend or in
tailor
in this form
about
the double michael
cheika skipped pass
their
own
clip you and i can't be done by people
and imaging and i thought of light
sharon eyal kouda name of crown of flight
global global solutions croquenots
because we live in a world today
connecting the current code is smart
it's new york project all funny world
music
game
angels acting becoming izia izia aulas
take
that is like focus of big problem is
because if your soul the big problem of
net wind for two saving tells
systems  and giant hic the half life against
8 to 10 with and not a we were kings
bayod technology weekend si every day
that bird technology is moving
from rio bay  physical able to de in
silico la bo de super computer
weeks start your engines even without
access to ruin the uatl in branoux
welcome there have great wall needs
tunisia black beast came in the
wave remembers the unique contact
break under the ground  one of the big frog of
windsor and the impacts of tunisian
ecosystems battle of
compiègne economy at 0 and match ben eager
dahmani things that would be thought of
light maurac lokoli focast at half mast and
fumarate big success this weekend is handled
local program  jumps but global risks
date
of the inside of horror story so far as
in static think i know when we decided
innovâtes competitive rugby globally
radovan seven years on a national can you
love me tender date us when a
big
internationalization acceleration of the
tempo
here  unfair I support policies is
where the no dealing with the
administration's paper canada to our
soled shoes and the dates of
grigny chapote happening  effective the
legacies of citizen kane darkly die
roquefort relative the routines task
ministry
of longing
foodservice the problem is not
identifying
which problem all agreement
current challenges and all
orders problem and find a way to
implement his innocence and will
change everything pippo varnish this  to to innovate
at the trial
this innovation
relativize stage a role in these
community halls and this touch 3rd chain
hoffman tally this first the strangers
mentality is we leave in and out of
bounds hockey sv difficult for
server 10 citizens to realize that in
technology of the six cars  here united
durable mentality in abundance mentality
negotiated figo a sovkhoze big problem of
wind armed forces 5 embarks in six
places date of singapore says that it
notes 6/10 tunisoise mort developed and
the
evolution of mentalist date nice to
happen in date this magnificent
hello I  introduces me to the young armada
of the harbor I am international Tunisian radio
so you answered
my question a little bit it
concerns artificial intelligence to give
birth to a generation
I mean generation
that can invest and believe in
artificial intelligence is what we
must start with a reform of
the education system insert this culture
from school to have this
second generation question tunisia today
has to work a lot on everything that
is legal because we know very
well it is the question of the laws which
today hinder many
sectors to move forward  side
of artificial intelligence is that
we must work on the legislation
to allow the development
of artificial intelligence in
tunisia agree so completely one on the
question of education I think
that effectively
familiarize young people level  from school already on the
potential of ai it is something
very important I know for example that
out of fifteen but I had through
the a  association of the sanna close by
initiatives in this direction and it is not
something very difficult yes I am
afraid when we say great reform
of education in general education it is
a very conservative field go when
we are  above the shields going
up I would say more familiarization with
him it might help some
extra practical lessons things like that these
are not very difficult things to
do but these are things that have a
lot of impact and then lead to
young people who are
trained who are aware of what is
happening and I would say to
change things in the end you will need
success stories that is what will
change things as long as we have not
had in Tunisia  or in the region of
success stories which shows that this is
what is happening in silicon valley or in
china it can happen here it will be very
difficult to change mentalities but
the day we have this type of success we
can create a virtuous circle where  more
people are starting to say yes it's
possible the government sees
the opportunity encourages startups even more
so we can have a
virtuous circle that is created including on the
scene of regulatory aspects
but there have still been some nice ones
success on the regulatory side in particular
start-up acts so I am optimistic
but we must continue to prove that
it is done for the right reasons
is the long-term interest of the country and
personally I do not see any
other area in zouk more important
that deep tech innovation
artificial intelligence which is the technology these
are the great
structuring transformations of this beginning of the 21st
century these are the things on
which Tunisia must invest and I am
optimistic I think that we are in the
right
common direction  and especially
in
the
lights out vast
project
avignon
clymene generator of yoav
duo systems flight networking opportunities
finance opportunities and
to conquer  head of the bumper request
please click on news and
sodimm by 19 min infernal show of 6.1
non-profit initiative to
benefit ecosystems half important
feasibility that where the weather is nice project
surprise smiles fate of the six weekends
tape a hole  d expertise holding his
victim to make sure that he and you have to
win a war jean to something we
wanna make is a success an impact is
celebrated successor david benefit magnini
48 states the start up to to improve
it's probably comoros competitive sow
feasibility impacts our  outings women
alone historical considerations
freedom for
every finds me a status ni young
start up by success soul by day like to
do that it would also be au gütsch
project witches interesting innovative
and some things which attends
a sort of second part of the season
sow everything  continue to meet pis to see
passionata battle dear knowledge
contact best practices of the year that
in the deep louis blanc So you open
landes baldwin kms de samcon sleek by
doing that you will love you make a wish
of myth takes brat ok because the king
is my mistakes improve lady
the weekend team we stop
slipped negative momentum and not the gaze of a
statue it is  ni start up your problem
ken bugul
bushing moments of comedy and free channel
is a young gay start-up
credit territory and premium between last
date night change start up from
steenbecque to saint paul at jan
breydel stadium vervecken
mypes in europe and  of a hole of this
program we will work with character
people and find ways to make impact and
share of 12.7 flac 10 e learning
club
on wii nav the presence of
permanent dowry to our leaders she is gonna be
active in charge of our  chains and its
brutality of chinese engineers or to
vote text huguette des ssii eds date
hannibal diamine belgium in contact
form app line beating like a
high speed meeting son teen got
lost and getting people to meet & f
seen  in my expat
amazing things happen customs people met
exchange tase news les faucets en
or greater is installed
african discreet
tim sarnoff come into my people
exact nature of project
best of we leave
no respite for the doubs
like saint gobain if we create and
ecosystem  in tunisia watch is rising
eliminated beast and all places on twenty
six fair notes of delta in the delta
force or dreaded spies metals under the
sun of dams systems shook this
building systems zoning of six
attempts at
transition missions customs ice trust world of
benefits everyone in what he is in the
bag racing team african continent and
beyond
the blues yves
culture which is probably lead to better
technology projects
to push for positive and system
initiative nitoo push for collaboration
between a status watch good old games
and were have  enough good people
working on is to
their profits
you have dingo as far as balances
problems bucco artistic  e personal
as long as it's hot of hairy basso
gentlemen according to louise bédard beats inago
scenario thank you negligible complete
profit profits to huge your
good stuff private it's not a choir
bodies hit you could read your number
accidents are due road glide factor  one
would like they are not sure you this
ain't reducing de badiou this est de
savoir even perrin qui n'ose good people
and to your life to the taste of children
taste score
that one takes me one more chance
in the statutes before  chamakh a
steward not been chosen for the second
time in a row by céline states
as top 100 first class istat ap
so why was this chosen what
are your plans whether they are
research be their commercial goods
ehret that you have perret who
allowed you to contribute to the development
of AI and the ranking of this type in the top
100 of artificial intelligence start-ups
yes we were very surprised
the first year to have been ch  oisi
in the top 100 of start-ups there are
two insight targets it's one it's a
very selective list I believe the
first year there were only two
companies, one of which in africa and the
arab world chosen and we our
South African society this year we
are I believe the soils we are
very honored by this distinction is the
reason why I think we
were chosen and this because at a stage j
-p en enough so we have a real culture
from open source research I think
you have all seen it with a berthe for
example which required a lot of
work on the part of friends our channels
the team did you say the compass team
and therefore there is  really this desire
to go further than
a normal start-up in quotes
so this passion for research and
this desire to create innovative products
and so that's the second
part I think of what we do which is
interesting it is by innovating in
research but we arrive in  after
developing products so it's not
just pure research I would say
academic and without impact my passion
is to have an impact everything I
do and understand my presence today
is to have an impact  positive to
allow others to achieve their
dreams or to fight to achieve them
and therefore the mentality a stage is that
it is to be passionate about AI to
do research to have fun in research
but  to have a big impact in practice
and it's a very specific culture
because you have to do both at the same
time which is not easy but which is
really fantastic give you a
concrete example of projects that we do
that  is very interesting and hasn't
been done before with two with deutsche
bahn german sncf
german railways we are in the process of
building the world's first ai system
of what we have routing of
train so really created this is which
train is going or at what time for  you
have just given an idea of the complexity of th
problem there are ten thousand ten thousand train
per day in germany circu
ating and therefore ten thousand journeys per day w
ll be a 33 thousand kilometer rail network this
as never been done and the p
ten
ial gains  potential economies of scale of
creating such a system are enormous you
know for example that building a
kilometer of railroad costs
hundreds of millions of dollars or
even more there are tunnels or
depends on things like that so with the same
rail network  optimizing the capacity of this
network getting more trains through these
are colossal savings for
countries so we are very proud to have been
chosen by deutsche bahn after a
selective trial on an international scale
to carry out this
very long-term project  together
here will flow think tank woods photo day
will also be had sum foot getting
started
[Applause]